bonjour bienvenue dans ces caches une
émission qui vous est présentée par un
irresponsable bientôt déchu de sa
citoyenneté
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ces
caches au menu cette semaine cela ne
vous a pas échappé le pass vaccinale va
donc faire son entrée dans notre
quotidien aura-t-il un impact sur
l'économie c'est la question que l'on
doit se poser on parlera aussi du rsa et
du rapport de la cour des comptes qui
pour la première fois fait un bilan de
ce dispositif
place ensuite aux investissements
étrangers et puis enfin votre banque
peut-elle fermer votre compte courant du
jour au lendemain on va à s'interroger
sur cette pratique qui a touché de
nombreux français est dernièrement une
actualité économique est chargé et bien
sûr décrypté par olivier delamarche
bonjour là bonjour celle face à vous
cette semaine philippe béchade bonjour
vous êtes le rédacteur en chef de la
bourse au quotidien bienvenue dans cette
émission c'est bonjour fille allez on
commence avec la première actualité le
passé vaccinale bien sûr l'un va-t-il
selon vous les vire impacter notre
économie sachant que l'on vivait déjà
depuis plusieurs mois avec le pass
sanitaires à écouter je vous avais le
conseil économique et social qu'il a
sorti un brillant rapport nous
expliquant que en gros
si ma tante en avait on en avait on
l'appellerait tonton bas c'était à peu
près ça c'était à peu près de ce niveau
c'est à dire si on n'avait pas eu le
pass sanitaires et bien on aurait fait
des dizaines voire des centaines de
milliards de moins de pib si on n'avait
pas eu le passage du ter y aurait eu des
milliers de morts en plus si on n'avait
pas eu le passé à lithaire on aurait eu
les dix plaies d'égypte qui nous serait
tombé dessus bon malheureusement
ce genre d'exercice si vous voulez ne
sert strictement à rien alors évidemment
sauf à rémunérer les gens qui le font
mais c'est tout c'est comme tous les
conseils qu'on comprend ce moment auprès
de mckinsey ça sert pas à grand chose
mais en tout cas ça sert à rémunérer
mckinsey ce qui est plutôt bien pour eux
donc
non on n'en sait rien honnêtement
simplement ce qu'on peu ce qu'on peut se
dire c'est que déjà on a complètement
désorganisé les entreprises là depuis le
début de l'année c'est épouvantable pour
la bonne et simple raison que dès que
vous avez un môme dans une école qui
alco vide eh bien vous avez tous les
parents à la maison pour le garder et
pour garder toute la classe et donc vous
avez des entreprises qui aujourd'hui
tourne à
50% et encore et donc qui en plus près
les prennent l'inflation de
l'électricité de deux des matières
premières et les ruptures
d'approvisionnement à cause du duc au
vide et à cause de ce qui se passe dans
les différents ports etc et donc vous
avez aujourd'hui
le pass sanitaire pèsent sur l'économie
contrairement à ce que dit monsieur le
maire et le pass vaccinale pèsera encore
plus puisque fera de
6,10 millions de personnes puisque vous
en avez en permanence qui sont
désactivés je vous rappelle des passes
parce que ils n'ont pas eu leur
troisième ou leur quatrième dose et bien
vous aurez
donc des gens qui ne pourront plus
circuler qui ne pourront plus aller
travailler qui ne pourront plus
consommer donc évidemment ça pèsera et
s'apaisera fort sur le l'économie mais
je dirais à la limite on s'en fiche
puisque il ya quand même un truc qui est
génial c'est ça s'appelle la planche à
billets et ça fonctionne très bien et
donc on peut s'endetter jusqu'à plus
soif toute façon à un moment on mettra
un petit coup de tipp-ex et tout ira
bien alors philippe béchade vous et vous
olivier l'évoqué j'aimerais vous faire
réagir justement à cette étude du
conseil d'analysé économique le cee qui
estime que le pass and i ter a eu des
effets bénéfiques sur notre économie
notamment parce qu'il a poussée à des
personnes à la vaccination et qu'une
augmentation de la part des vaccinés
dans la population de 1 point de
pourcentage a permis d'augmenter le pib
de 0,6 0 52 point de pourcentage un mois
plus tard ainsi sans le pass annie terre
à la fin 2021 le pib est de madère
aurait été plus bas en france de 0 6%
selon le cae
votre regard sur ce qui est dit est ce
qu'on peut considérer que le pass
vaccinale aura le même effet que le pass
sanitaires là dessus non mais là je cite
une hallucination complète c'est
un organisme qui est totalement en
cheville avec le premier ministre qui
pond une étude qui ne s'en de rétro
ingénierie c'est à dire qu'on vous donne
une hypothèse et va falloir que vous
trouviez tous les calculs alambiqués
pour aller confirmer le résultat qu'on
vous a demandé de faire apparaître donc
parmi les arguments que je crois que
seulement merveilleux c'est que si on
n'avait pas eu le pass sanitaire le
racket est obligé de tout refermer et si
on avait tous refermer là on aurait
perdu du pib non mais et si on regardait
du côté des pays qui ont rien faire mais
qui n'ont pas de passe si on regardait
leurs résultats économiques on pense par
exemple un pays comme la suède par
exemple ou maintenant on peut regarder
aussi du côté
de l'espagne on peut regarder du côté de
nombreux pays d'afrique voir si le pib a
chuté en période de pandémie sur
l'impact du passage du kazakh ne laisse
que selon vous il y aura un impact
négatif bien là déjà il est évident
enfin la sncf et l agonie un faut quand
même dire les choses évidemment les
chiffres ne sortent pas rien ne sort
mais actuellement
la sncf et ils ont ils ont une baisse de
30% des réservations transactionnel
impact négatif sur l'économie c'est en
gros ce que vous absolument pas la
fréquentation des restaurants des salles
de cinéma
là je pense qu'on aura les chiffres
je pense qu'on est actuellement jeu là
aussi je vais prendre un chiffre
j'essayais de minorer par rapport aux
échos que j'ai c'est que c'est une
baisse de fréquentation d'environ -30%
voilà alors pendant les fêtes ça
effectivement pas mal marché avec king
semaine avec deux trois blockbusters
effectivement il ya eu pas mal quand
même deux mondes est passé le 2 janvier
tout est retombé complètement
il ya une semaine je suis passé devant
le café le café de la paix
donc il y avait le banc des fruits de
mer etc mais il n'y avait aucune tables
occupées à 13h à l'intérieur d'un
établissement comme le café d'en face et
ça c'est hallucinant ça replonge et on
le sent on le voit on quand on discute
un petit peu alors évidemment c'est ces
organismes comme le disait philippe on
leur donne le résultat ils doivent
trouver comment y arriver ils sont
incapables de toute façon même en temps
normal de prévoir le pibe à chaque fois
vous avez cinq révisions pendant l'année
donc il arait le le pipe qu'il prévoyait
en début d'année et le pipe qu'il
prévoit à la fin de l'année n'a
absolument rien à voir donc vous
imaginez bien qu'avec qu'en temps normal
il n'y arrive pas d'accord c'est une
catastrophe leurs prévisions alors
n'imaginais pas que avec ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui et dont on ne sait rien
c'est à dire je vous ai dit plusieurs
fois quand un port bloc en chine et bien
évidemment toute la chaîne puisqu'on est
en stock zéro en flux tendu où
toute la chaîne est désorganisée donc ce
genre de choses on ne peut pas le
prévoir et donc ça donne des
catastrophes donc le pass vaccinale et
le pass sanitaire avant n'ont pas
apporté des points de pipe mais au
contraire vont en retrancher et en
retrancher un paquet très probablement
en plus avec le pass vaccinale qui va
être évidemment plus dur et qui donc va
empêcher un certain nombre de personnes
en france de deux vivent normalement
mais si on va tout de suite passer à la
deuxième actualité de la semaine
c'est le principal outil de l'état pour
lutter contre la pauvreté le rsa le
revenu de solidarité active a été créée
en 2007 pour remplacer le rmi d'un
montant d'environ 565 euros pour une
personne seule il coûte 15 milliards
d'euros chaque année il est versé à plus
de 2 millions de français et est censé
être un tremplin vers l'emploi
remplit-il ses objectifs non à en croire
un rapport de la cour des comptes le
texte pointe plusieurs échecs du
dispositif explications avec le tiroir
kashan reste
[Musique]
dans un rapport salé la cour des comptes
par la voix de son président pierre
moscovici vient d'épingler et de pointer
plusieurs échecs du rsa
d'abord près de 30% de ceux ayant droit
600 mille ménages n'y ont pas recours la
faute notamment à un défaut
d'information
malgré cette aide les bénéficiaires
rencontrerait d'énormes difficultés 43%
du mal à se chauffer 30 % se
restreignent pour acheter de la viande
est autant déplore des découverts
bancaires fréquents le rapport pointe
également du doigt les départements et
pôle emploi censé prendre en charge un
suivi faire signer un contrat
d'engagement et ainsi faciliter un
retour à l'emploi des bénéficiaires
le rapport constate que seuls 40 %
auraient signé le contrat dans des
délais largement supérieurs à ceux
prévus et dans 76% des cas les contrats
selon les mots de la cour des comptes ne
contiennent aucune action visant à
inscrire les personnes dans un parcours
de recherche d'emploi bref des échecs
flagrants pointé dans un rapport qui
tombe justement alors qu emmanuel macron
a ramené sur la table le 6 janvier
dernier son nouveau dispositif le revenu
universel d'activité r u à fusionner le
rsa l'apl aide personnalisée au logement
et la prime d'activité une proposition
qui sera sans doute un élément phare du
programme du futur candidat macron
olivier à simplifier le dispositif et
améliorer l'accompagnement de ses
bénéficiaires ce sont les
recommandations de la cour des comptes
parce que c'est suffisant
voulait
tout les tous les deux ans ou tous les
ans on vous change on vous change
l'ordre des lettres où on vous change
les trois lettres en se disant qu'ils
avaient pas eu de rmi rsa est ce que ça
a changé quelque chose pour ce qu'il
touche je crois pas donc et c'est ce que
la cour des comptes dénonce mais le
dénonce je dirais que ça tombe bien
c'est ça va dans l'ordre des choses pour
instaurer le le revenu universel donc
tous à
ccc blanc bonnet et bonnet blanc c'est à
dire que les choses tombent bien au bon
moment pour que justement monsieur
macron puisse proposer sa réforme sa
réforme qui sera quoi qui sera de
remplacer quelque chose par revenu
universel après peut-être une une idée
de l'étendre mais mais dans un premier
temps ça ne changera strictement rien
c'est à dire qu'on l'appellera autrement
mais ça ne ça ne changera rien et en
plus comment voulez vous aujourd'hui
vous avez une inflation qui est quand
même assez importante et sur le
chauffage comme comme on en parlait dans
tiroirs cage sur l'électricité sur le
l'essence pour les voitures etc comment
voulez-vous avec un peu plus de 500
euros vous en tirez et vous loger et
c'est donc évidemment que c'est pas un
tremplin pour quoi que ce soit parce que
avec 550 euros vous êtes à la rue 1 faut
dire les choses correctement il est déjà
je vais vous laisser répondre mais ce
sera juste après la pub
bienvenue dans ces cas chez vous nous
rejoignez au sommaire cette semaine est
l'actualité économique de la semaine
décryptées par olivier delamarche et
philippe béchade rédacteur en chef de la
bourse au quotidien philippe béchade est
ce qu'il faudrait par exemple fusionner
toutes les prestations sociales le
revenu universel d'activité qui
regrouperait par exemple le rsa l'aide
personnalisée au logement ou encore la
prime d'activité ce que c'est une bonne
idée
je vous avouerai je suis vraiment pas le
mieux placé pour en juger
concentré toutes les aides possibles
en une sorte de package je dirais
pourquoi pas si ça simplifie
effectivement la vie des gens quand on
parle des allocataires du rsa on parle
quand même de gens qui sont en souvent
en grand de détresse sociale et
psychologique
on parle souvent de familles où
pratiquement tout le monde se trouvent
hors rsa et je dirais presque de façon
quasi héréditaire est là
il n'ya malheur strictement aucune forme
des de prise en charge sociale cerc il
faudrait que l' image de faim je pense
que le dispositif aurait une efficacité
si on est dans une économie réellement
solidaire une économie de la proximité
c'est à dire que si votre voisin vous
savez qu'il est en difficulté votre
voisin votre voisine votre voisin
voisine et leurs enfants
il faut là dans ce périmètre c'est là
qu'il faut agir c'est pas en
en
déversant de l'argent façon hélicoptères
monnaie
sur des gens qui de toute façon son
redire à l'intérieur ils sont déjà un
petit peu
un petit peu sortis du système ce qu'il
faut c'est non seulement leur donner de
l'argent mais les remettre dans notre
dans notre vie commune
donc tout ce qui pourrait aller vers
plus d'inclusion vers plus de formation
ça ça me paraît très positif après cela
se demander si administrativement ça
c'est mieux de deux gros groupes et les
appelle les allocation handicapé tout ce
que vous voulez on l apurement dans du
traitement de tableaux excel on plaque
là encore du mécanique quelque chose qui
qui qui arrive du sommet c'est la pire à
ccc pyramidale sa descente on plaque
encore du du mécanique sur de l'humain
on a besoin à mon avis de beaucoup plus
d'humains que d'argent parce que
l'adresse la détresse psychologique
si vous rajoutez 50,3 euros 80 au rsa
singles 5,25 aux apl puisqu'on l'avait
retiré 5 aux étudiants il ya deux ans si
on remet 5 plus le coût de la vie 5,25
ça va résoudre au caire et à
l'accompagnement de au coeur des
problèmes voilà aucun des problèmes je
pense qu'il faut il faut rajouter de
beaucoup d'humain dans notre société et
faire beaucoup moins d'excel est
beaucoup moins de raisonnement
d'énarques
olivier vous l'évoquez tout à l'heure
les prix de l'énergie il ya des tarifs
réduits pour les bénéficiaires du tarif
réduit mais le si vous voulez vous avez
vous avez un taux de pauvreté qui a
augmenté fortement en france est
parallèlement à ça vous avez bruno le
maire qui nous dit qu'on n'a jamais eu
moins de chômage que aujourd'hui donc
faut arrêter je vous rappelle d'ailleurs
que c'est aussi ça le problème des
chiffres du chômage c'est que les deux
millions d'allocataires du rsa ils sont
sortis du système et donc ils sont
invisibles dans les chiffres du chômage
sauf que vous pouvez les mettre dans les
chiffres du chômage et à ce moment là
vous êtes plus à 5 millions 6 vous êtes
à 7 millions 6 d'accord donc tout ça
c'est du cdu c'est du tableau excel
c'est du comptable c'est parce que de
toute façon ils savent pas gérer
autrement que comme ça donc par petites
fiches et par tableaux excel sortie de
sa basse et la panique parce qu'on leur
a pas appris et donc
et donc aujourd'hui ça les amène à vous
sortir ce genre de rapport dont on a
parlé précédemment
par le comité qui dépend directement de
bercy donc
voilà par les investissements étrangers
pour l'édition 2022 choose france 21
projets d'investissements ont été
annoncées en france elle cela représente
plus de 4 milliards d'euros
d'investissements avec potentiellement à
10000 emplois créés notez qu'en france
1,8 million de personnes travaillent
déjà pour une entreprise étrangère
olivier je vous entends encore sourire
avec
prendra concrètement pour qu'on
comprenne et avec ce genre d'annoncé des
projets déjà amorcé vous savez ce genre
d'annoncé de la com' préélectorale
d'accord purement de tous les horizons
il ya un salon de choses france tous les
ans on a l'air mais oui on aime ou qu'on
l'appelle pas bientôt luz france aussi
un donc plus qu'autre chose donc
le le le problème de ces investissements
de sociétés étrangères qu'on annonce à
grand renfort de publicité c'est que
très souvent il ya une contrepartie
corps est la contrepartie c'est quoi
très souvent c'est une contrepartie
fiscale donc on va promettre à des
entreprises si elles viennent
s'implanter que d'abord on les embêtera
pas trop sur les licenciements qu'ils
annonceront après parce que évidemment
la preuve quand vous arrivez vous
annoncez pas aux gens que vous allez
tous les licenciés ça c'est l'année
d'après vous le faites un et est donc on
vous laissera gentiment faire et et vous
aurez une déduction fiscale ou des aides
pour vous installer pendant une période
donnée et vous remarquerez que
curieusement à la fin de cette période
mais qu'est ce que font les entreprises
elle re des ménages dans le sens et
elles vont s'installer à un endroit où
on va à nouveau leur faire des
conditions avantageuses pas d'impôts etc
pour pour s'installer et donc vous avez
ça mais ça faisait pas c'est pas
dernièrement c'est pas quelque chose de
de nouveau c'est quelque chose qui dure
depuis des années et vous remarquerez qu
à chaque fois qu'il ya une élection
curieusement pas on nous annonce des
merveilles sauf que quand on fait le
bilan un an deux ans trois ans plus tard
et bien le balance devant ne ressemble
pas forcément à lausanne ont justement
selon l'elysée les quatre éditions
précédentes dutch schultz france ont
généré en cumulé 13 1300 emplois et 8
milliards d'euros philippe béchade est
ce que ce sont des chiffres colossaux
est ce qu'on peut dire avec ces chiffres
que la france est un pays attractif tous
les ans pour les investisseurs étrangers
c'est pas des chiffres colossaux 1 le
pib de la france et trois mille
milliards d'euros voilà on parle de
quelque chose qui irradiait qui
représente ces zéros derrière la virgule
mais on réjouissons-nous effectivement
qu'on ait eu effectivement des projets
d'implantation d'une usine de recyclage
je crois de composants
plastique
et au delà même des 10000 emplois que
cela représente je pense que si on
rajoute les cdi on va rajouter 15000
personnes de plus donc réjouissons nous
maintenant la question que je pose c'est
puisqu'on est dans l'idée que la france
est très très attractive et si on
faisait une balance de ce qui sort c'est
à dire des entreprises qui étaient en
france et qui ont sont en sortie donc on
entend parler aujourd'hui la 2de
fondering bloc moteur qui qu'ils ferment
nos pneumatiques qui ferment on a des
tas de des d'état de fermeture au nous
annonce 300 600 800 licenciements
donc ça c'est ce qui est le plus visible
parce que là où on se situe en fait dans
l'idée de l'art et industrie et de la ré
industrialisation la france donc on va
sortir peut-être de trois usines avec 5
600 personnes combien en at ont fermé
l'année dernière l'année d'avant et je
rajouterais même
dans le tertiaire c'est à dire
l'industrie des services où nous sommes
se disant des champions combien
aujourd'hui
d'emploi sont exportés depuis qu'on a
découvert le télétravail on a découvert
qu'un indien qui parle très bien anglais
pouvait faire aussi bien qu'à un salarié
français pour trois fois moins cher et
24 heures sur 24 donc j'aimerais bien
que quelqu'un fasse une étude voir par
exemple espèce de conseil économique et
social ou et qu'il est qu'il fasse
l'inventaire de tous deux les usines de
tous les ateliers confirmer l'année
dernière combien d'emplois ont été
exportées vers des pays à bas coûts et
depuis qu'on est en télétravail combien
d'entreprises
annonce à leurs salariés que on a
restructuré un petit peu la façon dont
fonctionne et leur l'or
[Musique]
oui enfin l'administratif tous à la
gestion des projets tous à sa part sa
part à l'étranger ça coûte beaucoup
moins cher et là je vois bien savoir
effectivement si la balance de schultz
ronces elle est positive ou négative
chaque année ça ça ça s'appelle un
portrait vraiment la preuve que la
france est ou non attractive parce que
si vous avez plus dix mille emplois et
que vous en avez moins douze mille voire
moins 20000 avec le télétravail
l'interet pause il sait pas voilà la
balle à la balance à mon avis elle n'est
pas du tout favorable et je ne vois pas
en tout cas aujourd'hui comment on va
enrayer l'hémorragie des emplois avec le
télétravail les banques peuvent-elles
fermer votre concours ans sans préavis
c'est la dernière actualité de la
semaine
des clients de l'année aux banques
allemandes e n 26 ont été confrontés à
la fermeture de leur concours en selon à
des témoignages recueillis par rmc
environ 500 clients de cette banque ont
vu leur compte fermé ils n'ont a priori
pour le moment pas pu récupérer leur
argent la cpr le gendarme bancaire
français a été alertée et la somme et a
assommé les banques de s'expliquer n 20
6 n 26 assure avoir agi dans le cadre de
la nécessaire lutte contre la fraude et
le blanchiment d'argent nous fermons des
comptes lorsqu'il ya des soupçons de
fraude ou de blanchiment a expliqué le
directeur général de n 26 aux échos
olivier est ce que effectivement c'est
une pratique courante de fermer un
compte comme ça et est ce que est ce que
la banque doit ce justifié vous avez de
plus en plus souvent et là je vous parle
de mon expérience vous avez de plus en
plus souvent des problèmes avec les
banques c'est à dire que les banques on
sent qu'elles sont plus en plus nerveuse
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
d'argent qui sort de france par peur de
ce qui peut justement se passer dans une
dans une banque et donc vous avez des
réactions qui sont quelquefois curieuse
c'est à dire que très souvent la banque
considère que c'est son argent et pas le
vôtre donc elle vous pose des questions
qu'elle n'a pas à vous poser elle elle
vous bloque quand vous voulez faire un
virement ou quand vous voulez
acheter quelque chose sur facture extra
et vous avez des réponses qui sont
hallucinantes de banquiers qui se
comportent comme si c'était leur argent
et non pas le vôtre alors maintenant les
histoires de blanchiment écoutez
franchement si si tout d'un coup vous
avez 500 personnes qui sont qui sont
allés chez séché n 26 et qui se sont
fait bloquer leurs comptes pour soupçon
blanchiment je ne sais pas ce que c'est
que des soupçons de blanchiment mais ça
me paraît fort curieux si les chats de
rapidement est-ce qu'on est ce que les
gens peuvent avoir des recours quand on
sait fermer son compte bancaire comme ça
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire rien ah bin
là quand quand on ouvre un compte dans
un pays étranger dans une banque qui
obéit également à des règlements qui
sont qu'il faudrait connaître en fait il
faudrait dire toutes les conditions
avant d'ouvrir ce genre de conte
balles et les recours
ils peuvent être très difficile à mettre
en oeuvre et coûteuse titres classiques
par exemple dans une banque classique
forcément en france oui bah en france
déjà une banque classique souvent c'est
une banque de réseau donc si ce coup
votre compte est fermé vous allez
peut-être quand même tombé sur une
plateforme qui va prendre en compte
votre votre demande éventuellement vous
pouvez même vous rendre dans une agence
il fait face physiquement
physiquement oui il ya des recours parce
que en france je crois par exemple avant
la fermeture d'un compte il ya un
préavis de deux mois bon là de
semblerait-il en allemagne on peut vous
fermer du jour au lendemain et là bas le
recours déjà il faut avoir quelqu'un
c'est à dire que qui qui allez-vous
obtenir vous allez tomber sur un menu
vous avez une réclamation a dépassé
toutes les toutes les étapes et puis à
tous tous nos conseillers sont occupées
alors là ça sera en allemand bien sûr
donc c'est très réussi encore quand on
est quand on est dans
des services complètement virtualisés
déjà ça devient compliqué en france
parce que vous pouvez très très bien
passé dix appels sans avoir accès à qui
que ce soit quand c'est dans un autre
pays que c'est dans une autre langue et
qu'en plus de ça ce sont d'autres
d'autres règles qui s'appliquent ça peut
devenir effectivement cauchemardesque
donc attention à tout ce qui est à mon
avis complètement virtualisés parce que
là vous êtes contre une machine et
contre une machine si vous êtes aussi
devant une banquiers en france vous avez
quand même pas des milliards de moyens
de de vous défendre pourquoi tout
simplement parce que lui s'en fiche il a
une armée d'avocats derrière lui et que
si vous voulez aller jusque-là et mettre
un avocat en face c'est vous qui allez
le payer donc vous allez y passer un
certain temps donc à chaque fois qu'il
ya eu un problème avec une banque en
france vous aviez eu des problèmes au
monde 2008 sur des produits structurés
que soi-disant garantie xtra souvenez
vous savez durer un petit peu de temps
pour récupérer ses sous donc il faut
faire attention
aujourd'hui les banques sont de plus en
plus nerveuse et donc
d'être prennent leurs aises merci merci
et faire toujours la preuve de sa bonne
foi en permanence est aussi quelque
chose qui dit vrai qui devrait nous
interroger c'est à dire qu'on est
désormais toujours soupçonné d'être
d'être dans l'illégalité ou de ne pas
être conformes et ça aussi c'est une
dérive qui me paraît inquiétante même
édité cette dérive merci beaucoup
philippe béchade avoir été parmi nous et
je rappelle que vous êtes le rédacteur
en chef de la bourse au quotidien merci
olivier et c'est la fin de cette
émission merci de votre fidélité
prochain rendez vous la semaine
prochaine en attendant on se quitte avec
le traditionnel à derniers mots
d'olivier
sortait des banques 1